I'm Orlando Bloom and I play Rycroft
file of illustrate I'm Tamzin merchant
and I play image and span Rhodes and I'm
David Jesse and I play the grace
australe
we love our name and today we're gonna
be really cute just everybody be cute
for a second Oh first time I was
starstruck I met Emma Thompson oh yeah
right yeah and I just I couldn't speak
actually my tongue just just went so
drives like a desert in my mouth yeah
when I got to work on Lord of the Rings
I was in hit like a cast of like Ian
McKellen Ian Holm Christopher Lee Viggo
Mortensen Elijah Wood like it was just
like I was just like I'm starstruck like
Liv Tyler
oh my laptop I was probably about seven
mad into football we used to go to this
church and then this footballer called
Garth Brooks comes out of the church and
I was allowed to have my football with
me as a kind of coach things I go to
church no he didn't because he just came
to me it's like hey let me have let me
have a go on your ball nose like that
just remember going that's got script I
just kept going like that fool he was
like oh hey see ya and then my brother
and I run up to his car and then he
drove away
so Garth if you're watching yes listen
let's have a kick about first acting
credit or outside of school plays the
school plays Cal I did a blur video oh
wow and I was the boy that jumped the
fence what's the one that goes up boys
yeah had to run along it was one of
those likes s and I had to like just
jump fences Isum was a fencing film like
sword a sword fighting fencing film I
was a supporting artist on a bench dying
as Georgiana Darcy in Pride and
Prejudice yeah Jo Wright directed yeah I
know drop the mic I'm gonna have to
recount my first day well then if we go
in there I had no agent or anything I
called up the casting director he was a
number I found on the internet demanded
an audition faxed them a picture of my
face and they let me come on Edition and
I did three auditions and got the parts
when you fax them a picture of your face
is that you in a fax machine or do you
know I was thinking if I should read it
mine now because I'm feeling really
insecure about how good their responses
first time you met each other so I'll
start with Orlando I feel it creeping
inside me that I'm gonna get a dog and
I've come from a place of not really
understanding dogs or or being a bit
scared of them and I think my was in the
transition period when I met you and you
were holding my tea mm-hmm and I think I
sort of met my tea before you sorry man
no I listen but he's a great he's
illegal right he's okay but yeah and I
met you and you were nothing but love so
thank you for doing that because you
know it's can be intimidating so and you
weren't so thank you and then the first
time I met talons it was very
intimidating very intimidated I couldn't
speak remember what you did when you met
her Matata the first time I met you was
in an office in Prague and you came
around the corner and I went oh Tamsin
and you read oh where where huggy
yeah well we met at the read-through
yeah we met at the read-through and I
was intimidated because he had a massive
like fight like binder of the script and
I had like this little tatty machinable
vibe in like spoon big binder mystery
very organized and I do love a bit of
stationery so I had been station named
do - yeah I had a bit happen because you
had that Harry Potter happens yes well
she had a very cool Harry Potter her
kind of feels Barrett where did you get
that from the play from the Harry Potter
play
oh no oh I can't believe I was like why
is that and now actually yeah it's Harry
Potter I'm such a Gryffindor
[Music]